your first show on the podcast which has
been a huge smash hit you had your wife
on Christmas yes and and I was it was an
interesting experience for you because
it didn't quite go the way you thought
it would did it it didn't I mean I
should have been married Oh quite a
while sure yeah big celebrity couple and
you start talking to on your podcast you
think that'd be easy yeah I thought oh
this is a slam dunk for my first episode
I'll interview her we've done a thousand
interviews together this will be great
and it was a disaster right out of the
gates I think she thought I was trying
to unveil some big secret of hers which
I was not right and she also had had
plans to go to Michael's to buy crafting
stuff at the same time and then she was
annoyed that that was the day she was
supposed to be buying yarn or something
that really set her off and there's some
real bickering then there's some
bickering and then when I heard it I was
like oh my goodness you're so
controlling I thought I was a little
controlling but it was it was vomitus
how controlling I was and I really
thought I should hide the book this from
the public and then I later thought no
this is the whole thing you know the
sometimes we're in Samsung commercials
canoodling at Christmastime and
sometimes we're screaming at each other
about Michael's yeah that's just how it
is it's gonna be open and honest about
these things you're also very honest
about the fact that you are very you've
said that you're very glad that
Kristen's more successful than you why
well because when we met when we first
started dating I had more money than her
and I owned the house that I lived in
and she said to me at one point would
you like a prenup because you're gonna
get married yes we were getting married
and I said no I don't want a prenup
but I really wanted a prenup
right really bad you really wanted it I
really wanted a prenup
but I said no I don't want one because
well just meet something good came over
me for once
yeah and I made the right decision hey I
love you the joke is now on her because
she's become much more successful than
me and has much more money than me
or does she yeah
[Applause]
you